PRESIDENT IN THIS REPORT.
WE'LL SEE.
LAURA.
>> Laura: THANKS SO MUCH.
JOINING US NOW FROM, KEN STAR,
ROBERT RAY.
ALSO FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTORS.
KEN, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
APPARENTLY TONIGHT WE'RE GETTING
WORD AND SEEING SOME VIDEO --
THERE'S ANOTHER EVENT GOING DOWN
THERE IN PALM BEACH.
BUT IT'S A CELEBRATORY MOOD.
SHOULD THEY BE CELEBRATING?
>> I THINK SO BECAUSE THERE WILL
BE NO MORE INDICTMENTS.
WE'VE SEEN A VINDICATION OF LAW
IN THE FACE OF POLITICS AND
MEDIA AND THE LIKE.
WHAT WE SAW TODAY IN BILL BARR,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S LETTER,
IS A LETTER THAT SIMPLY IS
GROUNDED IN THE LAW.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN REACTION
FROM CAPITOL HILL IS, WAIT A
SECOND, WE DON'T EVEN WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE LAW AND THE
TRADITIONS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT YOU DON'T DRAG
PEOPLE'S NAME THROUGH THE MUD,
THAT YOU SAY JOHN DOE
HYPOTHETICALLY, ARE REALLY BAD
PEOPLE BUT WE CHOSE NOT TO
INDICT THEM.
THE REGULATIONS THAT CAME INTO
EFFECT IN 1999, INCLUDING THE
REPORT TO CONGRESS THAT LED TO
THE IMPEACHMENT OF BILL CLINTON,
CONGRESS SAID, WE DON'T WANT ANY
MORE OF THAT.
AND THESE REGULATIONS, I THINK,
ARE VERY CAREFULLY CALIBRATED TO
PROTECT THESE KINDS OF BASIC
PRIVACY INTERESTS AND THE
REPUTATIONAL INTERESTS OF THE
PEOPLE NOT BEING CHARGED.
>> Laura: THAT'S BEEN WAIVED OFF
TONIGHT.
THAT CONCERN IS BEING WAIVED
OFF, SAYING, SOL, I'LL GO TO
YOU.
THIS IS NO LONGSTANDING RULE,
THIS CAN BE DISPENSED WITH.
SCHUMER TODAY CAME OUT.
HE LOOKED LIKE HE JUST LOST HIS
BEST FRIEND.
BUT HE CAME OUT TODAY AND SAID
THIS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE MUST NOT BE
ALLOWED TO INTERFERE IN
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT PART OF
THOSE FINDINGS OR EVIDENCE
SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC.
IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR MR. BARR TO
MAKE THE FULL REPORT PUBLIC AND
PROVIDE ITS UNDERLYING
DOCUMENTATION AND FINDINGS TO
CONGRESS.
>> Laura: NOW, SOL, I THOUGHT
MUELLER WAS THE GOLD STANDARD.
TWO YEARS, THE DEMOCRATS,
MUELLER, MUELLER, MUELLER.
NOW HE DOES THIS REPORT.
APPARENTLY IT'S NOT GOING TO
GIVE THE DEMOCRATS WHAT THEY
WANT.
AND THEY'RE LIKE, NO, WE WANT TO
SEE YOUR DOCUMENTS.
WHAT WOULD THIS MEAN FOR THOSE
TO BE TURNED OVER?
AND IS THERE A LEGITIMATE REASON
FOR DOING SO?
>> WELL, I'M FOR TURNING OVER AS
MUCH AS CAN BE TURNED OVER IN
FAIRNESS AND IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE LAW.
FIRST OF ALL, THERE'S NO WAY
IT'S GOING TO ALL BE TURNED
OVER.
IT CAN'T BE UNDER THE LAW TURNED
OVER RIGHT AWAY IF THERE'S ANY
GRAND JURY MATERIAL IN IT.
AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE A COURT
ORDER, EVEN BEFORE YOU CAN TURN
THAT OVER UNDER SEALED TO
CONGRESS.
WE HAD TO GET A COURT ORDER.
IF THERE'S ANY GRAND JURY
MATERIAL THAT IS TURNED OVER,
THERE HAS TO BE A COURT ORDER.
SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
BUT BILL BARR HAS ALREADY SAID,
I WANT TO BE TRANSPARENT.
I WANT TO TURN OVER AS MUCH AS I
CAN.
I WILL SAY THIS.
I VERY MUCH AGREE WITH THE
PHILOSOPHY THAT SAYS YOU SHOULD
NOT SMEAR A PERSON IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO INDICT THEM.
AND I THINK THIS REPORT WILL
FOLLOW THAT PRINCIPLE, EXCEPT I
THINK THAT THEY WILL -- IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT THEY'RE FIXATED
-- THE MUELLER PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
FIXATED ON THE OBSTRUCTION
QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU WILL FIND
IS A DISCUSSION OF EFFORTS TO
STYMY THE MUELLER TEAM.
I THINK IT'LL BE DONE IN A VERY
DISPASSIONATE WAY.
I THINK THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
VIEW OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRECISELY BECAUSE HE CAN'T BE
INDICTED.
I THINK THEY MAY GO AFTER HIM A
LITTLE BIT WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A CRIMINAL
CASE, BUT I THINK THEY'LL TALK
ABOUT.
>> Laura: SCHIFF ON ANOTHER
NETWORK CONTINUED TO SAY, GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THERE'S ALL THIS
INFORMATION OUT THERE THAT THE
PRESIDENT OBSTRUCTED THE PROBE,
WE NEED ALL THE INFORMATION.
IT WAS LIKE THIS REPORT ISN'T
EVEN COMING OUT AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO REVEAL WHAT WE KNOW,
IT'S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
REVEAL WHAT THEY WANTED.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THEY'RE
FANTASIZING THIS AWAY IN THEIR
COMMENTARY TONIGHT.
WHAT ELSE DO THEY DO?
THEY'VE SPENT TWO YEARS USING
WORDS LIKE TREASON, COLLABORATE
WITH PUTIN AND SO FORTH.
NOW THEY'RE AT THIS POINT, AND
I'LL PLAY A SOUND BITE FOR YOU,
WHERE ONE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
CHIEF CRITICS IN CONGRESS IS
TALKING ABOUT MOVING THE GOAL
POSTS AWAY FROM EVEN OBSTRUCTION
TO JUST A GENERAL HONOR CODE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANT TO KNOW WHETHER THIS
PRESIDENT VIOLATED CONDUCT,
WHETHER HE VIOLATED NOT ONLY THE
LAW BUT THAT HONOR CODE THAT WE
ALL COUNT ON.
>> Laura: ROBERT, WHAT'S THE
HONOR CODE THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT?
>> I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA.
I MEAN, THE ONLY THING THAT'S
APPLICABLE ARE THE STANDARDS
THAT ARE EMBODIED IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND, I MEAN, THAT'S ARGUABLY BY
IMPLICATION THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS, WHICH GETS TO ONLY ONE
QUESTION, AND THAT IS, WHETHER
THERE'S A VIOLATION OF THE
PUBLIC TRUST?
BUT IN GENERAL HERE, BEWARE OF
EFFORTS TO MOVE THE GOAL POST
AND WHICH PART OF OVER, MEANING
O-V-E-R, DO THE DEMOCRATS NOT
UNDERSTAND?
I THINK, SOME PERSPECTIVE IS
IMPORTANT HERE.
IT'S AN INVESTIGATION THAT WAS
CONDUCTED OVER A PERIOD OF 22
MONTHS.
IT IS NOW CONCLUDED.
THAT'S THE END OF IT.
NOW, IF CONGRESS WANTS TO, IN
THEIR INFINITE WISDOM THROUGH
HOUSE DEMOCRATS, TO CONDUCT
THEIR OWN INVESTIGATION, THAT'S
ONE THING.
THEY DON'T HAVE SUBPOENA POWER.
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
AND WOULD BE CORRECT IN DOING
SO, RESIST ANY EFFORTS TO
ESSENTIALLY DUMP RAW DATA OVER
INTO THE CONGRESS VOLUNTARILY.
I DO THINK THAT CONGRESS IS
ENTITLED -- AND I AGREE WITH SOL
ON THIS POINT -- AS TO THE
PRESIDENT ALONE, THAT CONGRESS
IS ENTITLED TO BOB MUELLER'S
FINDINGS, THE BASIS FOR WHY HE
EITHER DECIDED TO BRING CHARGES
OR NOT, IN THIS INSTANCE, NOT TO
BRING CHARGES.
THAT MUCH I THINK IS SOMETHING
THAT CONGRESS APPROPRIATELY IN
ITS OVERSIGHT CAPACITY IS
ENTITLED TO AND SHOULD GET.
AND I DON'T THINK, FRANKLY, I
DON'T THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
RESIST THAT.
>> Laura: NO.
>> AND I THINK COOPERATIVE, THE
MESSAGE THAT SEEMED TO BE SENT
TODAY BY THIS LETTER IS THAT
BILL BARR, IN CONJUNCTION WITH
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND BOB MUELLER
IN THESE REMAINING DAYS, AND I
THINK THIS WILL HAPPEN FAIRLY
QUICKLY, WILL BE DELIVERING UP
THOSE FINDING TO THE CONGRESS IN
AN APPROPRIATE FASHION.
>> Laura: I THINK THEY WANT TO
PULL MUELLER UP TO TESTIFY ON
CAPITOL HILL, MAYBE BRING BILL
BARR UP AGAIN.
BECAUSE, AGAIN, IT'S ALWAYS THE
NARRATIVE SHIFT.
WHEN THEY DON'T GET WHAT THEY
WANT, WE HAVE TO SHIFT TO
ANOTHER POINT.
ALTHOUGH, THERE ARE STILL MEDIA
FOLKS, WHICH I THINK THE REAL
COLLUSION IS THE MEDIA WITH THE
DNC WHO ARE KEEPING THIS THING
GOING.
BUT CHRIS HAYES LASTING NIGHT
WAS SAYING THIS ABOUT WHAT HE
WOULD BELIEVE.
>> LET'S SAY MUELLER SAYS, LOOK,
ALL THESE THINGS HAPPENED, THE
PRESIDENT HAPPENED IN THESE
WAYS, BUT THERE WAS NO ACTUAL
COLLUSION, OR EVEN SAYS FURTHER
AND SAYS, WE EXONERATE THE
PRESIDENT.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE CAN DO THAT.
BUT DO YOU TRUST THE OUTCOME OF
WHATEVER THIS IS, WHATEVER IT
SAYS?
>> Laura: AGAIN, JOHN, MUELLER,
THEY BUILT UP HIS
PROFESSIONALISM AND REPUTATION
AND A LOT OF US CONSERVATIVES
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE MAKEUP
OF HIS PROSECUTORIAL TEAM.
AND THE DEMOCRATS SAID YOU
COULDN'T QUESTION BOB MUELLER.
BUT NOW YOU CAN'T TRUST THE
REPORT WHEN IT COMES OUT.
WHERE DOES THIS LEAVE US TODAY
IN THE PUBLIC FEAR, LOOKING AT
THE PROSECUTORIAL PRIORITIES OF
THIS COUNTRY, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
HOW DID THIS PERIOD AFFECT THE
INTEGRITY OR THE TRUST, I WOULD
SAY, THAT PEOPLE HAVE IN
INSTITUTIONS LIKE THE AMERICAN
MEDIA?
>> LAURA, I CAN TELL YOU,
PRACTICING IN THIS AREA, THAT
THERE IS A LACK OF CONFIDENCE.
CONFIDENCE HAS BEEN SHATTERED.
BUT MUELLER HAS BEEN HELD UP AS
A DEITY.
EVERYONE SAYING, LET'S WAIT FOR
THE MUELLER REPORT.
AND I HAVE NEVER SAID IT'S A
WITCH-HUNT.
I THINK IT WAS A LEGITIMATE
INVESTIGATION.
BUT WHAT EVERYBODY'S FORGETTING
IS HE'S A PROSECUTOR.
HE'S NOT JUDGE, JURY AND
EXECUTION...
AND THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS.
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
SPECIFICS ARE.
BUT I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
ENTITLED TO HAVE HIS
REPRESENTATIVES READ IT AND
PREPARE A RESPONSE, BECAUSE
PROSECUTORS ARE ADVOCATES.
THEY'RE NOT THE BE-ALL AND
END-ALL.
AND FURTHERMORE, CAN I SAY ONE
OTHER THING WHERE I'VE GOTTEN
SOME PUSHBACK FROM SOME OF MY
GOOD FRIENDS WHO ARE MORE ON THE
LEFT?
I'VE SAID THAT DURING THE COURSE
OF THIS PERIOD, THE PRESIDENT IS
ENTITLED TO THE PRESUMPTION OF
THE INNOCENCE.
AND PEOPLE COME BACK AND SAY,
THAT'S ONLY IN A COURTROOM.
BUT THIS IS THE PRESIDENCY.
AND AN INVESTIGATION LIKE THIS
IS A CLOUD OVER ANY PRESIDENT.
AND LIKE ANY CITIZEN, HE'S NOT
ABOVE THE LAW, BUT HE'S NOT
BELOW THE LAW EITHER.
WHY ARE WE NOT ASSUMING HE
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG?
AND ONE OTHER THING.
IN WATERGATE, WE ARE ROADMAP,
WHICH A JUDGE ALLOWED GRAND JURY
MATERIAL TO GO TO THE CONGRESS,
BUT WE DIDN'T DRAW ANY
CONCLUSIONS.
WE DIDN'T EXONERATE AND WE
DIDN'T FIND ANYONE
INCRIMINATING.
WE JUST PROVIDED CITATIONS AND
EVIDENCE AND LET THE CONGRESS
MAKE ITS OWN DECISION.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO GET ALL OF YOUR
REACTIONS TO SOME OF THE WORST
WRECKLESS ACCUSATIONS FROM OUR
FORMER INTEL CHIEF.
>> DO YOU STILL BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT COULD BE A RUSSIAN
ASSET?
>> I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE.
I THINK THAT'S WHY WE STARTED
OUR INVESTIGATION.
AND I'M REALLY ANXIOUS TO SEE
WHERE DIRECTOR MUELLER CONCLUDES
THAT.
>> MORE AND MORE, I COME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT AFTER THE
PERFORMANCE AND SINCE, THAT I
REALLY DO WONDER WHETHER THE
RUSSIANS HAVE SOMETHING ON HIM.
>> I USED THE TERM THAT THIS IS
NOTHING SHORT OF TREASONOUS
BECAUSE IT IS THE BETRAYAL OF
THE NATION.
HE IS GIVING COMFORT TO THE
ENEMY.
>> Laura: KEN, AID AND COMFORT
TO THE ENEMY, TREASONOUS.
WE HAD RENOWNED HISTORIANS
SAYING THE SAME THING.
ANY REPERCUSSIONS HERE?
>> ON THE DEEP STATE, WE SHALL
SEE.
I DO HAVE GREAT CONFIDENCE IN
MICHAEL HOROWITZ, THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HIS REPORT -- AND
I KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN COMMENTS,
WHY DON'T WE SEE THAT REPORT?
BUT IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
I DIDN'T EXPECT ANY REPORT ABOUT
POSSIBLE WRONGDOING WITHIN THE
DEEP STATE UNTIL AFTER BOB
MUELLER HAD FINISHED HIS WORK.
I REALLY THINK THIS SHOULD BE A
TIME, BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
BECAUSE WE ARE LIVING IN THE AGE
THAT WE'RE LIVING IN, WHERE
PEOPLE SAY, LOOK, HERE IS
SOMEONE, BOB MUELLER, VERY
RESPECTED, ATTACKED BY THE
PRESIDENT, IT COULD PRETTY V
VEHEMENTLY BY THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN WE GO BACK TO THE
ARTICULATION OF WHY HE WAS
APPOINTED, WAS THERE COLLUSION
OR CRIMES COMMITTED UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF COLLUSION?
AND HE CLEARLY MUST HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT THERE ARE NOT
SUCH CRIMES.
I THINK THIS SHOULD ACTUALLY BE
A TIME OF CELEBRATION THAT OUR
PRESIDENT WAS NOT INVOLVED IN
THE CAMPAIGN IN COLLUDING.
WERE THERE CONTACTS AND
COMMUNICATIONS?
OF COURSE, THEY WERE.
FINAL POINT.
WE'VE SEEN WITH WHAT I CALL FOR
A YEAR NOW CONTRA INDICATIONS OF
COLLUSION.
NOT ONE WORD IN THOSE VERY
DETAILED INDICTMENTS SUGGEST
COLLUSION.
AND THAT TELLS ME A LOT.
>> Laura: SOL, WE HAD JIM COMEY,
WHO KIND OF STARTED THIS ALL
WHEN THAT MEMO OF HIS, THE MEMO
TO THE FILE AFTER HIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT
WAS SENT OVER TO HIS PAL AT THE
NEW YORK TIMES, WHO LEAKED IT TO
THE NEW YORK TIMES, A PROFESSOR
AT COLUMBIA.
AND NOW HE'S SAYING THAT HE
DOESN'T CARE WHAT THE
INVESTIGATION UNCOVERS, EVEN
THOUGH HE STARTED THE WHOLE
THING.
HE KIND OF SAW WHERE THIS IS
GOING IN THE END AND HE HAD GONE
ON THIS BOOK TOUR, SPEAKING NOT
FAVORABLY, OBVIOUSLY, TOWARD THE
PRESIDENT, AND CLEARLY WANTED
THIS INVESTIGATION TO HAPPEN,
AND NOW IT'S KIND OF SKEDADDLING
AWAY FROM IT.
THOUGHTS THERE?
>> THERE'S A REASON THEY CALL
HIM SAINT JIM.
THAT'S ALL I'LL SAY.
HE'S GOT KIND OF A GOD COMPLEX.
I THINK YOU'VE RAISED AN
IMPORTANT POINT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN FORMER
DIRECTOR COMEY AND ANDREW MCCABE
AND PETER STRZOK AND THE FISA,
THE ALLEGED FISA ABUSES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT ABOUT.
WE ALREADY KNOW FOR SURE THE
FISA COURT WASN'T TOLD
EVERYTHING THAT BRUCE OHR TOLD
THE DOJ AND THE FBI.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THAT AND BETWEEN MUELLER'S
OPERATION.
MUELLER WAS ASKED TO DO THIS AND
HE DID IT.
AND I KNOW THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
THAT DISAGREE WITH SOME OF
MUELLER'S TACTICS.
AND I THINK HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
MUCH MORE CAREFUL IN THE TEAM HE
ORIGINALLY ASSEMBLED.
BUT I'M UNAWARE OF ONE UNETHICAL
THING THAT ANYBODY ON MUELLER'S
TEAM DID.
AND THIS WILL END UP BEING, YES,
THEY WERE TOO TOUGH WITH ROGER
STONE, YES, THEY PLAYED HARDBALL
WITH --
BUT NOTHING THEY DID WAS
IMPROPER UNDER DOJ RULES OR
UNETHICAL.
AND I THINK MUELLER IS A GREAT
PUBLIC SERVANT.
I'VE NEVER AGREED WITH HIM ABOUT
EVERYTHING, BUT HE'S A MAN OF
INTEGRITY.
AND THE IRONY IS, THIS WILL END
UP HELPING THE VERY MAN THAT
ATTACKED HIM RELENTLESSLY --
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NO ONE HAS EVER ACCUSED MUELLER
OF BEING ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THOROUGH.
HE SAID THERE IS NO CRIME
CONNECTED WITH COLLUSION.
>> Laura: IT IS KIND OF IRONIC,
IN THE END, IT LOOKS LIKE
MUELLER, HIS CONCLUSIONS WILL
BENEFIT TRUMP, AND THE
DEMOCRATS, WHO ARE PRAISING
MUELLER, ARE IMPLICITLY
CRITICIZING THE MUELLER FINDINGS
IF THEY DON'T GET ALL THE
INFORMATION.
AND THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY SKEPTICAL
OF THIS IDEA, YOU DIDN'T FIND
ANY WRONGDOING OR NOT ENOUGH
THAT IT RISES TO THE LEVEL OF
CRIMINALITY.
THEY'RE SKEPTICAL OF MUELLER.
SO IT'S KIND OF A FLIP DEAL HERE
IN THE END.
>> YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
AND BY THE WAY, "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" DOESN'T BUY THAT.
IN AND EDITORIAL FOR TOMORROW'S
PAPER, THEY SAY VERY POINTEDLY
IS THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THIS
HAS SHOWN IS THE LAW PREVAILS.
AND THE SECOND THING IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS VERY FORTUNATE THAT
HE HAD BOB MUELLER AS HIS
PROSECUTOR.
ALONG THE WAY, THEY TAKE A CHEAP
SHOT AT STAR BUT THAT SHOWS THAT
A LOT THAT GOES ABOUT HERE IS
SCORE SETTLING.
WE'RE GOING TO GET PAST THIS.
THE NEWS TONIGHT REALLY IS THAT
A FULL AND FAIR AND COMPLETE
INVESTIGATION WAS CONDUCTED AND
THAT --
>> Laura: ROBERT, I'VE GOT TO
JOB IN.
>> IT STOPS BEFORE THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: THAT'S TRUE.
BUT IN THE LAST TWO YEARS, WE'VE
HAD THE NATION IN THE VICE GRIP
OF THIS ANXIETY.
IT'S GREAT TO SIT HERE TONIGHT,
WELL, ISN'T IT WONDERFUL?
YEAH, IT IS.
BUT IT BEGS THE QUESTION, SHOULD
THIS INVESTIGATION HAVE BEEN
TRIGGERED THE WAY IT WAS, THE
FISA WARRANTS THAT WERE CLEARLY,
AT THE VERY LEAST, MISLEADING AS
TO THE TRUE PROVIDENCE OF THAT
DOSSIER, HOW THE DOSSIER CAME
INTO BEING, HOW IT WAS
DISTRIBUTED, WHO PAID FOR IT?
IT SHOULD NEVER HAVE HAPPENED.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS A VERY
CLEAR POSITION WITH REGARD TO
THAT.
AND HE MAY WELL BE PROVEN TO BE
RIGHT.
WE MAY NOT KNOW THAT UNLESS
THERE'S FURTHER INVESTIGATION
ALONG THE LINES THAT SOL IS
MENTIONING.
AND WE MAY NOT KNOW THAT UNTIL
WE HAVE THE BENEFIT OF HISTORY.
I'VE ALREADY SAID THAT WE
SHOULD, AND I THINK IT REQUIRED
NOT ONLY RELEASE OF WHAT
HOROWITZ HAS BEEN FINDING ALONG
THE WAY, BUT IT'S CLEAR ALREADY,
AS SOL HAS MENTIONED, THAT WHAT
HAPPENED, THE GAMES THAT WERE
PLAYED WITH THE FISA COURT,
ESSENTIALLY IS THAT THE INSIDE
THE DEPARTMENT, THERE WAS A REAL
DEBATE ABOUT THIS.
IT WENT FROM THE FBI TO
RESPONSIBLE OFFICIALS.
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
THEY PROCEEDED FORWARD WITH AN
APPLICATION TO THE FISA COURT
AND THEY DID NOT FULLY DISCLOSE
WHAT THEY KNEW, WHICH IS THAT
THE INFORMATION WAS BIASED.
>> Laura: AND AT THE SAME TIME,
JOHN, THERE WAS PRESSURE PUT ON
THE PROCESS TO NOT INDICT
HILLARY CLINTON FOR HER
EGREGIOUS ABUSE OF GOVERNMENT
PROTOCOLS AND CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION HANDLING.
SO THERE WAS PRESSURE, I THINK,
ON COMEY NOT TO DO THAT, NOT TO
PURSUE THAT.
SO, I THINK THERE'S A LOT -- AND
AGAIN, IT'S WONDERFUL THAT IT'S
TURNED OUT, IT LOOKS LIKE, THE
WAY IT HAS FOR THE RULE OF LAW
AND ALL OF THAT, BUT THE FACT
THAT THIS HAPPENED TO AN
INDIVIDUAL, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, AND LORD KNOWS
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES WE LOST IN
THE PROCESS ALONG THE WAY.
ALBATROSS TO THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
WHO KNOWS WHAT MAYBE WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
WITH RUSSIA TO HELP THE COUNTRY,
OUR SECURITY.
BUT WE CERTAINLY DIDN'T.
I DON'T WANT TO LET ANYONE OFF
HERE AS TO HOW THIS WHOLE THING
STARTEDED.
AND COMEY'S CUTE LITTLE OP-ED
NOTWITHSTANDING, I THINK PEOPLE
WANT THESE QUESTIONS ANSWERED SO
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN TO
ANYONE, LET ALONE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S ENOUGH OF MY SOAPBOX
HERE.
>> IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS TO BE THE VICTIM
OF WHAT REALLY ARE NEEDED
REFORMS IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST AS TRAGIC IF
IT HAPPENS TO ANY CITIZEN, AS
WHEN IT HAPPENS TO THE
PRESIDENT.
WITH THE PRESIDENT, WE PAY
ATTENTION TO IT.
WITH THE MUELLER REPORT, IF
WE'LL CALL IT THAT, NOW IT'S
GOING TO BE CALL THE BARR
SUMMARY.
THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS.
I THINK THE CELEBRATION IS A
LITTLE PREMATURE.
IT'S A VERY GOOD DAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT, BUT LET'S SEE WHAT
HAPPENS, WHAT DETAILS ARE THERE,
AND AS I CAN --
>> Laura: IT'S A HELL OF A LONG
WAY FROM THE PRESIDENT WAS
COMMITTING TREASON AND
CONSPIREING WITH PUTIN AGAINST
THE AMERICAN ELECTORAL SYSTEM,
WHICH IS WHAT WE HARD FOR
TWO-PLUS YEARS.
>> HOW COULD THE PERSON WHO WAS
SUPERVISING, ROD ROSENSTEIN,
THIS INVESTIGATION, BE A PERSON
WHO WAS TALKING ABOUT WEARING A
WIRE ON THE PRESIDENT?
>> Laura: THANK YOU.
I DIDN'T EVEN THINK ABOUT THAT.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
EVEN THOUGH MUELLER IS DONE
THOUGH, AND I THINK JOHN IS
RIGHT, WE'VE GOT THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK HANGING OUT
THERE, CORRECT, AND DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL WANT TO LAUNCH
THEIR OWN PROBE.
THEY, I DON'T THINK -- THESE
THINGS DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH RUSSIAN ELECTION ENTER --
INTERFERENCE.
THE LIST GOES ON.
>> THERE ARE ANY NUMBER OF
EXAMPLES THAT I COULD GIVE YOU
OF INFORMATION, INFORMATION
THAT'S BECOME CLEAR FROM THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
THAT MAY NOT BE NEATLY SUMMED UP
IN A DECISION OR A DISCLOSURE
THAT WE DECIDED TO INDICT A BUT
NOT B.
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAS
SPECIFIC MANDATE TO PROSECUTE
WITH THAT INTERFERENCE OF THE
ELECTION AND ONLY TO LOOK AT
CRIMES.
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW
YORK ALSO ONLY LOOKS AT CRIMES.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT A MUCH
BROADER QUESTION.
>> I DON'T SEE HOW HE DOES NOT
HAVE INDICTMENTS WAITING FOR
HIM.
>> Laura: THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE IS KIND OF FED
UP WITH ALL THESE REQUESTS AND
THEY BASICALLY ARE STIFF ARMING
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS ON THESE
RIDICULOUS REQUESTS AND FOR THE
MOST PART NOT RESPONDING.
KEN STAR, PROBLEMS ON THE
HORIZON, THOUGH.
THEY DO HAVE OVERSIGHT POWER.
A LOT OF THESE HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE PRESIDENT'S CONDUCT
IN OFFICE.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION.
BUT WE'VE MOVED TO POLITICS AND
THE 2020 ELECTION.
THE IOWA CAUCUSES, THE
DEMOCRATIC DEBATES, THERE ARE A
LOT OF CANDIDATES.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS FODDER FOR
THE POLITICAL PROCESS.
BUT HAPPILY TONIGHT WE'RE
TALKING MORE ABOUT LAW THAN
ABOUT POLITICS.
AND WE HAVE AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN BILL BARR WHO'S GOING TO TURN
SQUARE CORNERS AND GO BY THE
LAW.
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM CONGRESS
IS, WE DON'T WANT YOU TO ABIDE
BY YOUR REGULATIONS.
WE WANT YOU TO DO SOMETHING
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT.
WE ESSENTIALLY WANT YOU TO
BECOME OUR AGENT, HELP US IN THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
AND AS YOU KNOW, THAT WAS THE
STRUCTURE OF THE OLD INDEPENDENT
--
HAPPILY THAT'S GONE AWAY.
SO, IT'S BEEN A NEW DAY.
AND IF CONGRESS DID NOT LIKE THE
NATURE OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THESE REGULATIONS NOW FOR 20
YEARS, THEN THEY SHOULD HAVE
HELD A HEARING, TALKED TO AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND SAID, "WE
NEEDED A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION.
IF THE OCCASION ARISES, WE NEED
MORE INFORMATION."
THESE ARE MINIMALIST REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
NOW, I UNDERSTAND THE OTHER
SIDE, WHICH IS WE WANT MAXIMUM
TRANSPARENCY, BUT DON'T WE WANT
MAXIMUM TRANSPARENCY CONSISTENT
WITH THE RULE OF LAW?
WE SHALL SEE.
>> Laura: REALLY QUICK, SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE WHISPERING
ABOUT THAT TONIGHT.
PERIL AHEAD FOR THE TRUMP
FAMILY, THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
>> WELL, KEEP IN MIND, ANYTHING
IS POSSIBLE, BUT KEEP IN MIND
THAT RUMORS YOU'VE HEARD TO THE
CONTRARY NOTWITHSTANDING, THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT IS ACTUALLY
PART OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THEY ACTUALLY REPORT TO BILL
BARR AND HAVE TO TAKE ORDERS
FROM HIM.
I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT BARR
WILL NOT DO ANYTHING TO
IMPROPERLY INTERFERE WITH THEM
BUT HE WILL MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
HE WANTS TO BE KEPT ABREAST OF
THE INVESTIGATION AND I HAVE
GREAT CONFIDENCE IN HIM.
>> AS THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED
TO BE INFORMED, ANYONE -- AND
THIS IS WHERE THE MEDIA HAVE TO
BE VIGILANT.
ANYBODY WHO THINKS THAT THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK
SHOULD BE USED AS A STACKING
HORSE FOR THE CONTINUATION OF
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION, I
THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE THEIR
HEAD EXAMINED.
AND IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE SUPER
VISION AND TO BE MONITORED BY
THE DEPARTMENT IN WASHINGTON.
>> Laura: THAT TELLS YOU ALL YOU
NEED TO KNOW.